direction charte et l'atelier d'un
maître verrier et de son acolyte
graffeurs
ou tu meilleur à l'intérieur walsh a
tort
on s'est vu un peu des bouteilles écrasé
donc il a fallu en bois débouté pour
toutes ces oeuvres d'art en temps quand
on s'appelle kevin picole allez je vous
présentais killing maîtres verriers
depuis 19 ans et travaille avec son pote
pas ici dans cet atelier familial
[Musique]
je suis le papa de kevin autant pas
travail je vois ça va kevin bonjour ça
va très bien donc ça bosse dur l'avant
l'atelier parce que je suis content de
pouvoir justement voir de plus près ces
techniques du vitrail
c'est bien parce que les tâches sont
bien réparties cia ton père qui est à
l'avant de l'atelier qui est plus solide
traditionnelle et toi tu es plus sur ce
qu'on appelle le fusing c'est ça fait
donc c'est des techniques qui sont un
plus récentes et qui va nous permettre
aussi d'élargir notre gamme
ça c'est ce que vous retrouvez dans les
églises par exemple de ça c'est vraiment
là de la technique ancestrale nationale
et donc c'est quoi la différence avec le
fusing alors le fusing déjà iap les
plombs donc on est vraiment sur une base
que deux verres et l'ensemble après est
cuit dans un four à 832 gré pendant 24
heures et cela fusionner sa fusionner
ensemble
d'où la grande fusing voilà on peut
répartir sur un petit montage et ce qui
pourrait être sympa c'est de mélanger
justement le côté fusing donc moderne et
le côté traditionnel haka composants on
peut faire les deux par exemple pour
celle ci alors nous on va on va changer
on va pas faire ses couleurs là on va
les y voilà un peu dans dans ce principe
là bas avec des couleurs différentes
la première étape donc c'est ça va être
de découpe et notre support
donc on va utiliser ce qu'on appelle une
tournette donc la tournette c'est tout
simplement pour faire leur on voit la
tronche à s'appuyer non alors faut
vraiment appuyé sur sa trace ici voilà
donc déjà le premier cercle est donc là
on va s'amuser donc à ce moment là à
faire mieux que petite cuisine on a
préparé trois poudre à la greluche tout
ça donne du verre suis lassé du rose et
ça c'est du turquoise dakar voir toutes
ces notions l'en-tête surprise a fait
après la cuisson
donc on a emprisonné les poudres de
couleurs les élèves et entre deux
couches tout à fait des verts exactement
on va ensuite rajouté des petites poudre
de verre tous les pays propos ça va nous
donner une certaine texture ce qui va
permettre d'apporter de la matière une
recette de gâteau c'est smith et ça
c'était son le fusing c'est de la
cuisine
donc là nathalie ce que je te propose
c'est qu'on donc c'est qu'on prépare le
faut donc ça c'est le four ou les pieds
sont sont cuites donc donc là ce qu'on
va faire
la poudre que tu vois là c'est du
séparateur c'est un anti adhérents c'est
pour éviter c'est un peu comme du plâtre
c'est pour éviter que le vert il colle
au au tapis du fonds axa prend les
moindres détails
tout à fait ça sert à ça donc la
personne qui veut faire effectivement
une houle importe on peut faire en
textures et donc on peut inclure des
pizzas dans ton four c'est pas
recommandée mais on peut c'est parti
pour 24 heures depuis son super
maintenant on récupère notre pièce
centrale qui a été fusionné à 830 degré
et donc on va pouvoir mettre faire la
mise en plein déni
j'ai quasiment un 10 sur 10 1 par kevin
je pense qu'il est généreux il va tout
de suite les petits défauts donc
logiquement un vitrail si toutes les
étapes sont bien respectées on est censé
jamais le revoir
c'est à dire que normalement c'est à peu
près 100 150 ans une fois que c'est une
bonne mise en plus donc ça c'est qu'un
élément donc des vitraux qui sont là bas
si tu veux je t'emmène dans l'ailé donc
voilà les fameuses civ
vu comme ça ça change tout là ça change
quand même pas mal
donc c'était pour un ensemble pour une
exposition que dans la grande galerie du
château de maintenon
donc je travaillais avec un autre avec 1
un autre artiste qui après pas dre toute
la partie boiseries donc les vitraux
sont venus s'intégrer dans la boiserie
techniques ancestrales et technique
moderne voilà en fait le but c'est le
mélange c'est ce qui était totalement tu
as toujours su qu'ils travailleraient
dans le vert est un acte à un père qui m
v rim donc le vitrail traditionnel oui
mais de partir aussi sur le fusing une
technique que lui ne connaissait pas et
j'ai apporté ma petite pierre et autre
chose qui m'a frappé en arrivant
toutes ces bouteilles fondues alors j'ai
eu un jeu de moore était médisantes des
coups quand on s'appelait monsieur
people on essaye aussi de faire avec du
soft 1 donc bon c'est quoi mais non ça
c'est un petit peu moins soft mais c'est
pour la couleur
c'est vrai que chacune ont leurs
particularités et j'ai peint donc à la
bombe
car j'ai un ami donc graffeurs zkk tu
vas rencontrer tout à l'heure et
explique rage et son métier sa graffeurs
maîtres verriers voilà et on s'est
rencontrés par le biais justement des
bouteilles et celle avantage c'est qu'on
arrive à à combiner nos deux savoir
faire et je crois qu'il va pas tarder et
toujours à l'heure maintenant que vous
êtes cas nous a rejoint je vais pouvoir
découvrir l'univers et le travail de cet
artiste
le support are in one une bouteille
compressé est donc là le support a été
réalisée donc par kevin et toi tu te
casses à la technique ça va être un peu
particulier il va falloir tout à verser
tous les pots charbon être inversée pour
avoir le même effet ce qu'a la fin de la
pl la fin la plaque on va leur tournée
toi tu ne travailles pas par ordinateur
dans tout seul c'est à la main ton
premier dessin entre la main à tous puis
après tu graff à la main ce soit au
niveau des taux du travail que le blanc
le gris le noir est principalement mai
voit le noir et le blanc ça permet
d'avoir un clair obscur qui se fait donc
un effet relief et courtet rencontré
kevin on s'est rencontré sur un marché
j'ai vu cette bouteille c'est la
première fois que je voyais ça et c'est
le vert pour moi c'est un avant de le
rencontrer je conseille c'était
uniquement un objet qui cassent et après
j'ai vu qu'il pouvait vraiment faire des
choses incroyables comme les gouttes et
de coquins vraiment de type pop art
d'ailleurs on avait fait une
une pièce c'était une vierge connecter
sur des bouteilles de coca avec tous les
réseaux sociaux autour pour mettre en
adéquation justement le support est ce
que ce qu'on a souhaité dire dessus de
la barre ouais exactement je te propose
qu'on laisse sécher ce qu'on vient de
faire et on va passer sur une
application plus classique pour la faire
une petite surprise un camion à tunis
sur deux à kevin là c'est l'occase ça
c'est important pour toi qui est
toujours un message un derrière mais en
fait j'ai peint le passé juste c'est
juste une juste faisait juste pour créer
une échelle entre deux mondes pour que
les joueurs essaient de se positionner
on la regarde on s'est pas chacun fait
son avis à un maintien kevin regarder
travail attentats on va retourner pour
qu'ils admirent un peu tu as fait quoi
qui a fait quoi au 100 m haies bulleux
et où sont celles de erika j'hésite
entre deux c'est que c'est bien fait au
moins celle ci c'est ça il était trop
fort c'est qu'on a bien bossé pendant
dix ans ça se voit en effet un petit
truc
donc pour toi aussi ses geôlières alors
voir ce que vous propose ses
d'immortaliser ce moment est de faire un
self i à iii pour mon blog 2 3
la créativité de ces deux artistes et
leurs alliances du verre et du graff
voilà encore une belle en jeu profite
d'une courte pause sur ma route pour
leur dédier quelques lignes sur mon blog